[Music]
abandon all hope ye who enter here
this is the warning inscribed above the
gates of hell it's from dante's inferno
an epic description of the medieval
underworld whilst dante envisioned it as
a large looming door several
illustrations depicted the entrance to
hell as a giant mouth a gaping set of
jaws that devours the souls of the
damned these helmets are everywhere
cropping up in manuscripts prayer books
and paintings
even in early theater productions where
giant mechanical mouths were constructed
in medieval town squares
but where did this fighting image come
from many believe that the hellmouth has
its roots in norse mythology with its
hellish ideas of man-eating wolves and
devouring dragons
welcome to strange christian art this
episode hellmouths
[Music]
open up a medieval manuscript and you're
never too far away from spotting a hell
mouth or two there are some with two
heads some with cauldrons inside and
some who've bitten off more than they
can chew but my favorite is the one with
a mouth in another mouth in a castle in
another mouth
many of our helmets are from illustrated
prayer books particularly in sections
about prayers for dead people often
you'll find these uniquely disturbing
representations of hell
these lavishly decorated books would
have taken months if not years to
complete and were typically owned by
very wealthy patrons for those who
couldn't afford such things you could
get your hellmouth fix at the theatre
there are accounts of medieval stage
productions featuring these giant
mechanical mouths some could swallow
actors others were able to billow smoke
and shoot fireworks these so-called
mystery plays were designed to amaze and
frighten ordinary townsfolk using early
special effects to deter an illiterate
population from bad behavior you might
have guessed this already but the core
purpose of these helmets is to scare
people to frighten them into faith
enough so that they think twice about
skipping church on sunday the idea of
being eaten by gigantic monster mouth is
indeed a horrifying possibility
then again medieval artists also
pictured heaven as the domain of giant
eagles made out of human faces
i'll take my chances with the helmets
another place where helmets appear are
in the many illustrations of jesus
leading people out of its jaws this
popular image is known as the harrowing
of hell
it's based on the christian myth that
between his crucifixion and resurrection
jesus took a trip to hell to rescue
those who were born before his ministry
there are loads of images like this
where these monstrous mouths seem to be
spewing out naked people
these gruesome mouths reveal how
medieval christians understood hell
many artworks envision hell as one giant
kitchen
victims are thrown into a giant cauldron
cooked on a flaming grill and finally
devoured by satan and his demons mostly
though it's satan doing all the eating
in artworks you can see him lurking at
the bottom happily chomping down on
human remains
it's hell's kitchen but literal who'da
thought the gordon ramsay show is so
rooted in art history the idea that hell
is one macabre banquet was taken up in
the gruesome paintings of hieronymus
bosch as well as peter brugel the elder
their disturbing renaissance hellscapes
are full of demons gorging themselves on
unfortunate humans
and if you look carefully you'll even
spot the odd hellmouth
[Music]
the thing that's unclear however is why
depict hell as a giant mouth it's
undoubtedly a disturbing image but where
did it come from some of the earliest
depictions of hellmouths are from saxon
england although they might have been
inherited from norse mythology you see
in saxon times large swathes of england
were ruled by viking raiders
particularly in the north in a territory
known as the danelaw
it's why so many english words have
norse roots ransack berserk slaughter
and heathen are all scandinavian in
origin
even the word hell itself comes from old
norse it's the name of the goddess of
death who rules the underworld realm of
the same name
but it's more than just the word itself
that we got from the vikings even some
religious ideas about hell have roots in
norse mythology
in a small unassuming graveyard in the
north of england there is a stone
monument called the gosforth cross it's
particularly ancient having been built
by saxon christians in the 900s
despite it being a christian monument it
also depicts scenes from norse mythology
like the death of balder at the hands of
the trickster god loki who is later
imprisoned for his crimes
and then there's this one a scene where
the warrior god vithar tears open the
jaws of the great wolf fenrir
it is remarkably similar to those
christian depictions of the harrowing of
hell where christ similarly rends open
the jaws of a hellmouth
this jewel between vithar and the wolf
fenrir could be a precursor to the
christian hellmouth it might explain why
so many these hellmouths are so canine
in appearance they could have originally
been borrowed from norse iconography and
the great wolf fenrir the gosforth cross
could have been used to convert the
local viking population to christianity
and point out some similarities between
the two religions like the death of
baldur and the crucifixion of jesus or
the binding of loki and the imprisonment
of satan in the book of revelation
the gospel cross is one example of the
cultural effect the vikings had on saxon
christianity
other norse ideas about the afterlife
seem to have made their way in as well
in an anglo-saxon chronicle the devil is
likened to a dragon that devours wicked
people
this description is rather similar to
the norse creature nidhogg a great
dragon who lives at the bottom of the
world in a realm called nastrond the
corpse shaw trapped in this gloomy
cavern nidhogg chews on the corpses of
the wicked a grisly fate reserved for
the worst criminals in viking society
as with before it's believed that this
norse idea about the underworld might
have diffused into saxon christianity
and it might explain why those saxon
chronicles had such a similar
understanding of hell as the vikings
from giant canine mouths to greedy
corpse gobbling dragons these
christianized ideas spread from england
onto the
continent whilst our christian hellmouth
has its roots in norse iconography the
idea of a devouring monster and the
underworld isn't wholly unique to
scandinavia in the egyptian book of the
dead the hearts of the unworthy are fed
to the demon s amit her body is a mix
between a hippo a lion and a crocodile
the most ferocious beasts of the nile
the archetype of the devouring god is
present in various world mythologies in
some cases they seem to have arisen
independently of one another
all express the same idea that being
eaten is equated with spiritual death
that's what makes the christian
hellmouth such a powerful image and a
useful deterrent against wrongdoing
it appeals to a very basic human
instinct don't get eaten
in this life or the next
thanks for watching i had great fun
making this and i hope you enjoyed it
too
if you like this video and want to see
more why not subscribe a like and a
comment also go a really long way
anyway i look forward to seeing you next
time goodbye